I got some people in the chat that are
asking about Bob I know that
um some of you probably didn't watch the
last um
podcast on the unplugged Alpha but had
an in-cell on and uh dude was really
struggling now he gave me the green
light to show it to you gals if you guys
want to dive into that do you guys want
to maybe provide an assessment on what
you think of this guy's life as he holds
himself out to the public especially to
women
let's do it are you ready for that do
you guys want to take a look at it and
provide some feedback and let us let us
know what you think from your
perspective I think that would be an
interesting piece
I'm looking at it
naturally
what's your take on it like if you saw
him on a a dating app and he had his
Instagram linked and you saw that what
would you think
really good profile yeah I mean I don't
I don't hold on let me come back to the
stream here I've looked at it enough
um I actually think it's a really good
profile I don't see anything that stands
out that he's doing wrong
um so unless I unless I talk to him and
had a conversation got a feel of his
personality I can't really speak on it
further because his profile looks good
okay what do the other ladies think
I agree there's like nothing that stands
out as like a
as if maybe what the
typical things pop off in your mind
where you think of incel yeah because
um I mean he's a strike using in cell he
doesn't give off like install Vibes or
anything
um not really
cool all right
I wouldn't have guessed at least okay
Sophie
I can I mean I love to be able to read
people I think greeting people is great
obviously online is very difficult
especially on social media but I can
tell by the way he's holding himself in
his pictures the way he's posing it's
definitely giving off you know a little
bit of you know it could be a little bit
insecure obviously because he hasn't had
a girlfriend yet I think if he had a
girlfriend of some sort he'd be able to
you know come out of his shell a little
bit more maybe be able to pose a little
bit differently but I can just tell by
the way he's posing he seems very
insecure
seems insecure okay
Alexandra you're you're feverishly
looking away that your screen goes black
for a long time so you so you Dove down
the rabbit hole what have you seen
what's your feedback
yeah no I was just I was on my phone so
scrolling back and forth but he just
looks like he's really introverted and
that he keeps to himself he likes to do
things alone okay
um personally I I like extroverts okay
but if you saw his best photograph on a
dating app would you match with him
probably not
not Ashley
get your name yep I would yeah Sophie I
would not you would not Kayla
uh not my type but someone else's type
okay so we got one match out of the four
gals
I don't know moff like what do you think
about that feedback so far I've got a
few thoughts man
um I mean
I've seen a lot of guys Instagram
profiles and a lot of guys come to me
looking for help on optimization or how
to create a profile that looks good to
get attention of women and dating and
things like that and you know I think
the one thing he's got going for him
is that he's got a thin sort of Slender
face other than that
um it's clear the guy travels as well
but I I think he doesn't seem like he's
a guy that's super captivating or that
is living a life on his own terms I
think the Sophie's Point his body
language is lacking you can tell that
there's some self-confidence issues for
sure
you could tell he's trying to put some
effort into it but he's not he's not
quite there
mm-hmm
yeah
um yet I always find it's interesting
when women evaluate men because it's
like oh he seems like a nice guy and
interesting and he's got a great bio on
his Instagram stuff but it's like the
way that women tend to react to stuff
like this in real life would be well
he's only got 400 follows he's not that
interesting there's no pictures of him
with other people doing captivating
things it's just him standing in front
of Landscapes right
um so the so the saying and doing and by
the way like the doing part of it is the
activity of actually swiping writing
matching so we've only got one out of
four gals that would even make the
effort to swipe right which may or may
not turn into something he's okay did
you have something go ahead I think
Kayla raised her hand she don't send
something to add good yeah I just wanted
to speak on his profile a little bit
more so I would actually so I I
believe this doesn't give back to
anybody but I go to a very popular gym
and
um I actually like his profile more than
most the guys at my gym just because he
seems more genuine whether he's doing
things alone it's not a bunch of selfies
of himself in the mirror right so if I
had to choose between an attractive guy
at the gym who posts like that or going
out with someone like him where he seems
more genuine I would probably pick him
would you go out with a guy that's five
foot six 110 pounds
I know
I heard no I have Okay so let's do one
at a time five foot six 110 pounds
Alexandra yes or no
no why I think it comes down to
Lifestyle
okay is that you have to share a similar
lifestyle you have to have an active
um lifestyle and that doesn't always
come with genetics some people say okay
I'm five foot six 110 pounds that's just
the way that you know my mom or my dad
was or somebody else like that but
you have to have that discipline of
going after what you want and what they
want and you want it there may be a
disconnect and that's why for me it
would be a no because it doesn't the
lifestyles don't match
Kayla would you go out with a guy that's
110 pounds five foot six
I'm 110 pounds
um and I would say no
Sophie
I think it comes down to what they have
to offer I mean if he was a millionaire
would you guys change your
answer
you want it that's surprising yeah all
right well that's surprising anyways
um I would not personally
um
but if they had something to offer
whether that was Insight intelligence or
something else then I would absolutely
Ashley dudes five foot six hundred ten
pounds would you go out with him I've
dated someone that was was like exact
things before are you petite
no I'm five foot eight okay so I'd be
taller than him I've actually never
dated anyone's higher than me
um not by choice it's just like what's
happened in my dating life so and I I
agree with Sophie sort of
um I
feel like in the past I've sort of
enjoyed more of what they had to offer
yeah emotionally
okay interesting
um
so Bob there you go you got some
feedback
um but again as I always say in my
videos watch what women do watch what
the behaviors are not what they're
saying
um you're getting some mixed feedback
here and I think one of the things that
I've started to notice more often you
know you tell me if you've seen this too
is that
women seem to struggle
and I noticed this when we asked them on
the first one like what do you think of
lizzo like is she beautiful and they
were all like ah you know if she wants
to do that then she looks beautiful in
my eyes sort of thing then that's cool
too right but it's it seems like it's
difficult for women to overtly make a
statement that might be somewhat
judgmental I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out